à melisabeth Doisneau rapporteur général
de la commission des affaires sociales
[Applaudissements]
monsieur
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales monsieur le
Président Monsieur le rapporteur de la
branche vieillesse madame la rapporteur
pour avis de la commission des finances
mes chers collègues comme vous le savez
depuis 2020 la commission des affaires
sociales a souvent réclamé au
gouvernement qu'il dépose un projet de
loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale
afin que le Parlement puisse se
prononcer en temps utile sur les boules
de versements que cette crise a entraîné
sur les comptes sociaux trois années de
suite les prévisions et objectifs de la
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale ont été rendus caduques en cours
d'exercice aussi bien en recette qu'en
dépense pourtant nous n'avons pas été
entendus et c'est en ce début d'année
2023 que nous sommes saisis d'un
collectif social afin de porter la
réforme des retraites
alors même que les prévisions de la
dernière loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale n'ont pas été modifiées
en profondeur
je sais que c'est apparent paradoxe
motive une exception d'y recevabilité
dont nous débattrons tout à l'heure
j'indique tout de suite qu'à mes yeux un
tel véhicule législatif peut contenir de
telles dispositions la commission des
affaires sociales aurait d'ailleurs
mauvaise grâce à prétendre le contraire
puisqu'elle propose une telle réforme
depuis des années lors de l'examen du
projet de financement de la sécurité
sociale de l'automne
et sur le fond peu de mesure pourrait
tenir pourrait avoir un impact sur les
comptes de la Sécurité sociale
supérieure à celui d'une réforme
paramétrique des retraites
qu'un texte budgétaire soit le cadre
dans lequel le Parlement débat de la
pérennité financière de notre système de
retraite ne me choque donc pas au
contraire
il n'empêche que la plupart des mesures
que nous allons débattre auront un
impact financier à terme et que la
rectification des comptes de l'année
2023 n'est que mineur
en quelques mots le gouvernement n'a pas
fait évoluer les prévisions
macroéconomiques sur lesquels il s'est
appuyé cet automne
il ne fait donc que tirer les
conséquences pour la seule année 2023 de
la réforme des retraites proposées par
le présente
celle-ci sont faibles et font apparaître
une légère dégradation du solde de la
branche vieillesse de 0,4 milliards
d'euros et celle-ci est due d'une part à
l'augmentation des dépenses à hauteur de
600 millions d'euros en raison notamment
de la majoration des minimas de pension
et d'autre part en sens inverse à une
économie de 200 millions d'euros grâce à
la première application du relèvement
des bornes d'âge à compter du 1er
septembre
au total le déficit consolide d des
robes et du FSV seraient dégradées de ce
montant passant de 7,1 à 7,5 milliards
d'euros
j'ajouterai simplement que le
gouvernement a déposé à l'Assemblée
nationale un amendement qui n'a pas été
examiné visant à augmenter l'ONDAM de
1023 de 750 millions d'euros
en prenant en compte ce recalibrage la
dégradation du solde pourrait donc
dépasser un milliard d'euros par rapport
à la loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2023
les débats sur l'article de 15 si comme
je l'espère nous parvenons jusque là
vous permettront monsieur le ministre
d'expliquer pourquoi c'est ton dame 2023
doit être revalorisée dès à présent
alors qu'en novembre le gouvernement
soutenait contre la vie du Sénat qu'il
était parfaitement calibré
mais bien entendu le cadrage financier
le plus important intervient à terme
puisque l'objet même de ce texte est
d'organiser le retour à l'équilibre
financier de notre système de retraite à
l'horizon de 2030 dans un contexte
démographique délicat
à titre personnel je souscris à cet
objectif qui me semble cohérent avec les
positions que notre commission et
au-delà le Sénat ont défendu depuis
longtemps je relève qu'au fil de ces
années le message du gouvernement avarié
bien davantage puisqu'il s'agissait une
année de refonder le système sans
objectif financier puis de refonder le
système en l'amortissant d'un âge pivot
puis de le réformer de façon
paramétrique afin de financer toutes
sortes de dépenses publiques et
finalement comme le Sénat de présenter
une réforme paramétrique pour équilibrer
le seul système de retraite dès lors il
est difficile de reprocher à nos
concitoyens d'avoir du mal à suivre la
pédagogie puisque le mot est à la mode
né de la répétition et non des
changements des changements de pied
pour en revenir aux chiffres je les
reprends en quelques mots
les projections de l'année 2030 font
apparaître un déficit du système pris
dans son ensemble de quelques 13,5
milliards d'euros en l'absence de
réformes
il s'agit bien d'un chiffre annuel
dont le cumul creuserait une dette
susceptible de remettre en cause la
pérennité du système par répartition
créée à la Libération c'est à dire le
principe de solidarité entre les
générations qui fait que chaque
génération d'actifs finance par ses
cotisations les retraites de ces aînés
en comptant sur le fait que les
générations suivantes feront de même
face à ce trou de 13,5 milliards le
relèvement de l'âge légal et
l'accélération de la durée de cotisation
devrait rapporter
17,7 milliards d'euros en 2030 ce qui se
traduirait donc par un excédent
théorique de 4,2 milliards à cette
échéance
néanmoins le présent projet de loi
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale
contient diverses mesures dites
d'accompagnement
pour un total de 5,9 milliards d'euros
le trou donc de 1,7 milliards qui en
résulte a été comblé dans le projet
initial par deux mesures d'ailleurs
d'ordre réglementaire d'une part
l'augmentation de 0,12 points des
cotisations patronales vieillesse qui se
récompensés par la baisse du concurrence
des cotisations ATMP et d'autre part
l'augmentation de un point des
cotisations patronales de la cnr-a-cl
c'est donc d'un projet tout juste à
l'équilibre en 2030 par ailleurs fondé
sur des hypothèses qui les permit de
juger optimiste que l'Assemblée
nationale a été saisie le 23 janvier
comme vous le savez les débats n'ont pas
permis au députés d'aller au-delà de
l'examen de l'article de terre et seule
une mesure adoptée par l'Assemblée
nationale aura un impact financier
positif significatif
l'harmonisation à 30% du taux de la
contribution assise sur les indemnités
de mise à la retraite d'un salarié à
l'initiative de l'employeur et de celle
verser à l'occasion d'une rupture
conventionnelle c'est donc le l'article
de BIS dont le rendement en 2030 est
estimé à 300 millions d'euros
cependant nous le savons aussi le
gouvernement a déposé des amendements à
l'Assemblée nationale qui n'ont pas pu
être examinés mais qui aurait eu un coup
de l'ordre de 850 millions d'euros s'ils
avaient été adoptés
cette présentation quelque peu aride
mais chers collègues vise à montrer que
même si le Sénat devra naturellement
avoir ses propres marqueurs nous ne
disposerons que de fort peu de marge de
manœuvre pour adopter des mesures
généreuses en recette comment dépenses
les quelques marges existantes ont déjà
été utilisées il ne serait pas
responsable de notre part de voter une
réforme qui suscite tant des mois dans
le pays si nous ne rétablissons pas
véritablement la trajectoire budgétaire
de notre système de retraite
la vraie générosité la vraie générosité
pour les générations futures consiste à
leur léguer un système de retraite
financièrement solide et dans lequel
elles peuvent avoir confiance
je conquerai en disant quelques mots des
articles que j'ai pu particulièrement
instruire en dehors des articles
récapitulatifs l'article premier
concerne la fermeture de plusieurs
régimes spéciaux selon la clause dite du
grand-père concrètement les nouveaux
personnels embauchés à partir du 1er
septembre 2023 cotiserait désormais au
régime général et non plus dans le
régime spécial cette mesure concernerait
les régimes suivants les industries
électriques et gazières la Régie
autonome des transports parisiens
l'éclair est employé de notaire la
Banque de France et les membres du
Conseil économique social et
environnemental même si ces listes peut
sembler présenter un certain aléas les
régimes retenus se caractérisent par un
déséquilibre financier compensé soit par
une subvention d'équilibre de l'État ou
de l'employeur dans le cas de la Banque
de France soit par une taxe spécifique
la Commission proposera donc au Sénat de
s'en tenir à l'équilibre ainsi défini au
bénéfice de l'adoption d'un amendement
de coordination
l'article premier bis c'est introduit
demande de rapport que je vous
proposerai de supprimer par ailleurs
l'article 3 qui prévoit l'abandon du
projet de transfert aux urssafs de
l'activité du recouvrement de l'agir
Carco et de la Caisse des Dépôts et
Consignation constitue un motif de
satisfaction pour notre commission enfin
c'est dans l'annexe figure le principe
de l'augmentation des cotisations
patronales pour la cnr-a-cl je vous
proposerai au nom de la commission un
amendement introduisant dans la loi le
principe de compensation intégrale par
l'État dès 2023 pour conclure je
m'appuierais sur les propos de l'abbé
Pierre qui disait la responsabilité de
chacun implique deux actes vouloir
savoir et
oser dire notre responsabilité ici au
Sénat repose il me semble sur ces deux
volontés complémentaires comprendre et
débattre je ne doute pas de chacune et
de chacun d'entre vous chers collègues
notre haute assemblée sera se montrer à
la hauteur de ses enjeux je vous
remercie
en général
[Applaudissements]